good evening my name is Herman hills
from guerrilla games and I'd like to
welcome you to horizon zero dawn set on
earth more than a thousand years into
the future this is a world that's ruled
by amazing machines and a lawyer hero he
must use every element of strategy to
take down these fearsome foes
ido is only quest here and that quest is
to get a very specific resource from the
canisters on the backs of the machines
that were looking at here they're called
the grazers and the grazes are part of
an entire machine ecology where each
machine has its own unique purpose in
the world and its own unique resources
that a lloyd as the master craftsman can
use to craft new weapons new ammo and
new outfits
the combat is all about knowing your
enemies in your environments and Hanoi
is going to use an ammo type here called
the explosive tripwire in order to set
traps that she hopes she'll be able to
push this herd into
a couple of alpha grazers stuck around
here to defend the herd and to give it
an opportunity to escape horizon is an
action-rpg and you can see that the the
looting of the parts of the machines and
the crafting of items with that is a
major part of this game
crash oh no we just opened up deaf mode
to show you our mighty Thunder Hall
Thunder JA it's 24 meters long it's ten
meters high and you can see here the
sheer size differential between it and a
Lloyd now the Thunder job makes for a
very strategic fight it's got 93 armor
plates which cover the soft tissue
underneath and if you can zoom in on
these weak points it gives you a massive
advantage also if you zoom in here on
this disk launcher if you take that off
you might be able to use the machines
weapons against itself so you will
prevent it from from firing long-range
missiles at you you can pick up that
heavy weaponry and use it to your
advantage so let's get back into the
fight and actually recommend we get out
of the way here
thanks so much for having us here at
Paris games week we are looking forward
to bringing you arises here at all in
2016
[Applause]